donc votre nouveau single s'appelle par
amour donc forcément on va faire une
interview par amour avec tout le monde
et avant de faire j'aurais peut-être
aurait peut-être non j'aurais peut-être
une surprise pour vous tout à l'heure
c'est mais pour l'instant c'est d'une
interview par amour c'est parti king
[Applaudissements]
merci ya pas de jingle c'était pour voir
si on régime
il y avait une ligne du temps voilà
apparemment il n'ya pas de jingle
lemercier par amour est-ce que vous
pouvez pardonner une infidélité
anna est la vérité ça dépend de quel
type d'amour avis est-ce que c'est
l'amour d'une vie est ce que sur une vie
on peut glisser
j'ai glissé chef est ce qu'on peut
est-ce qu'on peut glisser sur une vue
d'une vie je crois que oui c'est bien
donc vous pouvez pardonner
ah ouais je suis un peu à welch yamcha
pour ça j'ai un peu l'héritage de ces
femmes de ces femmes du sud
moi je pense que parce je crois que je
serais capable en tout cas avec l'homme
que j'ai épousé je crois que l'on se
régale en soit ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut que tu bouges une oreille elle veut
pas dire qu'il faut que tu boulot rien
là je te le dis là là là là c'est bon je
peux glisser lévesque l'aller avec ses
potes les bêtes je peux glisser ou on
fait quoi que ce soit moi je suis plutôt
la femme du nord à ce moment là when
harry non là c'est pas possible on peut
pas glisser vous non mais si on est on
n'a pas des jets puis des anti dérapant
non parce qu'on fait que je pense qu'à
partir du moment où il ya une infidélité
le ver est dans la pomme est foutu un
driver exactement comme vous alors moi
je pensais que je pardonnerai pas et
puis si jamais ça arrive et maintenant
je me dis que finalement si et au bout
de quarante ans elle mais devrait faire
le job
[Rires]
jamais je parle aux garçons aussi madame
oui moi je pense qu'il ya une différence
entre la langue et le zizi pardon pardon
attendez c'est moi voulait nous donner
on a nous donner un cours d'anatomie
géant jaune et si vous me le permettez à
l'est excusez moi mais c'est qui celle
dr l'homme et un témoin vous allez
redescendre des initiatives et deauville
manière tu va te pendre d'epinal
arrabiata dans la gueule ça va te faire
tout drôle
alors qu'est ce qui se passe tout dépend
de comment la personne vous trompent
s'ils avouent trompe avec le zizi mais
qu'elle ne connaît pas la personne ni le
prénom et le sang de bois donc pas tant
d'avoir des béquilles c'est moi alors
voilà sivola ya un mec car il voit là et
vous êtes avec un mec il vous trouvera
en ce qu'elle est l'anglais
ce n'est pas parce que si ces faits sont
faux
c'est lui encore exactement suite
si vous avez une personne qui connaît le
prénom de l'autre personne qui attia de
l'affection pour l estime et sa langue
c'est pire donc je préfère votre unis
avec la zizique avec la langue d'accord
très bien voilà la leçon je vais les
actions mais qu'aussi daiwa
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
hier il a avec ses potes
attention les mecs je peux sortir mon
psy vous soyez sur tour mag
attention danger partout partout un
attaquant dit ça on dit qu'on est
capable de pardonner mais je suis
passionné vous disais qu'il y c'est la
fameuse question thierry ardisson est ce
que sucer c'est tromper exactement voilà
merci en tout cas d'avoir très bien
résumé bercy alors non mais c'est vrai
oui oui oui moi je tiendrai d'autant
plus que je l' ai déjà fait comme
beaucoup de ceux qui occupent ce qui ne
sont pas hypocrite j'ai déjà fait donc
je serais enclin à pardonner évidemment
et puis deux là je pardonnerai si elle
me l'avouer si je le découvrais ça
serait peut continuer à me l'avouer
serait plus facile ça et puis je prends
aussi le pardonne plus facilement si
c'était beau pas perdre mon job c'était
que mon boss par exemple ça se passait
là je pourrai pardonner progressivement
parce que je veux pas perdre ma copine
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ces paquets votre boss longtemps
figuerola ya longtemps au figaro très
bien à un dos pas vous nous direz que
dans les z'amours parce qu'on a une
vidéo qui correspond et mais qu'on bosse
là dans les hameaux il ya une femme qui
apprend qu direct son mari s'est bien
amusé de son côté après une dispute
regarde après un break notre relation du
coup on a je suis sorti avec mes amis on
est sortis en boîte et je n'ai pas dit
mais vous aviez des vues sur une meuf ou
pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout vu
tout draguer vous avez une amie c'est
une amie c'est une amie qui quelqu'un de
kaka mais je pense que toshiba va tomber
tétines ficelles
elle était là et ça n'a pas plu du tout
voilà que je passe cette soirée là avec
elle mais qu'elle ait revu depuis
cette sophie oui bien sûr ouais d'accord
mais non tout bientôt
on te défendre
c'était un chantier la même date à côté
une sombre affaire à bras à la mais là
il ya eu langue ou autre il ya eu langue
ou autres merci on vous appellera cela
besoin d'un amusant merci ah non mais
c'est bon un ça va c'est bon par amour
là est ce que vous pourriez arrêté de
chanter
non ça ce serait comme arrêter d'avoir
les yeux noisette dirais pas en quoi
c'est impossible
bah je vais pas chanter ses commandes
d'un magazine
tu n'aurais pas arrêté d'être ce que je
suis à chanter c'est ce que je suis un
bon bah vous je vous pose pas la
question non arrivée au quai le chanteur
moi je pourrais pas ça arrive à une
telle perfection que ça c'est ça vous
rendez vous pourrez pas arrêté de
chanter c'est hilarant je vais te dire
j'espère qu'un jour tu feras la promo de
mon album j'ai décidé de me lancer dans
la chanson titre de l'album
ça c'est le problème chez une autre ça
serait le deuxième déjà fait quand il
pète les trous sont ce les postes à
double disque de platine a exercé au
plus on descend de deux étages
c'est pas moi c'est carbone qu'on
emballe et la brassée par coup pas sur
un coup de foudre est ce que vous avez
déjà coucher le premier soir
oui avec mon mari
non c'est bourges et latoya jackson non
jure sur la toya toutefois le premier
sas on considère qu on a passé 24 heures
à parler on n'a pas dormi et finalement
on sait revoilà donc oui allô prof
en tout cas c'est moi jamais quoi jamais
le temps de latence qui pour vous par
exemple 24 ans
oui beinheim oui bin hammam et vous êtes
romantique bah oui oui franc il voulait
pas lâcher un peu non mais sérieux euros
là chez moi quoi c'est bon vous aviez à
coucher le premier soir
tatave vercingétorix
[Rires]
va t bonds nancy la vérité tout à fait
normal qu'il a dit la vérité
bah oui avec mon mari ces beaux arts
était auparavant vous m'avez demandé par
amour nombre est par amour oui est-ce
alors j'enlève le par amour non non
jamais non jamais qu dit avait été non
ménard vous au mas a dû m'arriver oui
oui quand j'étais jeune ça m'intéressait
vous soyez là non j'étais jeune j'étais
un petit point que vous étiez mannequin
jouey l'alva mieux j'étais au jeudi à
auzat au défilé là on a été mangé dans
un restaurant le yak et choucha et là je
vois un mec mais magnifique à franco
australien qui me dit what is your name
et là je lui dis il n'y a pas de prénom
n'y a rien c'est toi et moi sur ton
sushi bay comme ça le recteur ne sent
pas bien sûr ça fait chatouiller le nez
du phare
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et tu fait de tes meilleurs amis h le
genre je te le jure
parce que c'est le cas d'une demoiselle
qui s'appelle sonia dans mary au premier
regard qui a prévu d'y aller à fond a
dès la première nuit benhaim je vous ai
pas demandé non alors moi non non non
moi je suis moi il faut faire à
l'ancienne quoi moi oui c'est à dire à
hofu de bois quoi pour la paix au moyen-
discuter on est sûr que nous ne parle ni
tes ratures allemagne
oui j'adore ces jours sur la toile est
un peu de voix là de civilisation des
lilas à la prompte anatomy la non moi
jamais j'aime beaucoup trop de fierté
j'ai trés j'aurais trop peur de
nouvelles de banana shpeel hp cloud qui
alors de nouvelles alors je vais vous
dire je pensais qu'on sexe pas de
nouvelle bonne nouvelle en nombre au jeu
du jeune homme